hi everyone I see as I feel correctly
pointed out that my talk is the
technology that bill image identify and
I thought it would be a relevant talk to
have actually was quite last minute
thing I guess well I expected image
identified to be as popular as it was
actually when it when it when it first
when it first well when I first heard
about it but uh so I thought instead of
just generically talking about machine
learning in our machine learning
capabilities i talked about image
identify now if you want to tweet you
know this is the best talk you've ever
seen or something like that hashtag ewt
see 2014 and my handle is a time's up
nick and i'll just make a tweet now 2015
no sorry did I say 2014 well 2015 it
says it there this is it there okay wow
that's what's quite small okay so what I
want to talk about today is how image
identified calm was built so I don't
want to just talk about well image
identify the function but I want to talk
about the the cloud concepts behind in
how its structured obviously I'll talk
about the function and how you can use
it and this kind of leads on into me
talking about machine learning as well
get our main functions classify predict
now also I feel like when you come to
conferences like this you want to see
what's going to happen for the future
you know what's coming in 10.2 and
beyond so I also have some stuff that I
can show you as well so first of all I
mean you've seen it image identify com
it's a very very nice microsite that we
build and we got some sample images
which I guess we probably cherry-picked
but you know it's nice so we can drag
this this image of a car or a coupe and
it and it and it tells us one of the
things we can do is I'm part of the
reason why we're doing this is to allow
people to aid
us in our image identification project
so if this was wrong I could say it mr.
point and it tells us at the Bombers of
its more zoom that hasn't worked and all
that it gives us some examples
potentially that it might be and then
you can you can say what you think it
was and submit and actually I just say
it was a coupe I guess this will still
work and you can enter your email
address and yeah and then well it used
to say that you get wolfram t-shirt it
doesn't do that anymore oh uh well just
help us it's very nice helping us we'll
help you so why why did we create this
website well there's an actual
application for image identification if
you wanted to know what species and
animal wars or something of the sorts it
demonstrates our machine learning
capabilities it demonstrates how cloud
capabilities as it was like entirely
built with our cloud platform and it's a
way to crowd source identification of
additional images so I got some examples
let's have a look okay so let's see how
well these are pictures I taken or stole
from facebook pages I think so here's my
motorcycle like I'm telling my life
story so yeah it's correctly identified
a motorcycle this is this is something i
made it was supposed to be a Spanish
omelet it wasn't very edible I will see
what what image identify thinks it is
and it thinks it's a lasagna well I
wouldn't call it a Spanish omelet either
so I guess it's quite a difficult I
don't know what to call it so you know
lasagna is fine it doesn't always get
things right you have to be aware but
but I can see where it's coming from
here we've got canal venice oh let's
changed interesting last time i did this
you see this is this is what happens
with these with these algorithms is that
is that they update
and originally said canal and now it
says building because it's uh well it's
obviously identified that the buildings
on the outside apart from in and not the
canal so this is like live updating so
it's good to know scissor one of my
colleagues not here ah he's a he's I
don't know I don't know where he's
sleeping I'm on I don't know but but
yeah sleeping bag very good oh yeah
there's a couple here so I got we got
the new Joker I don't know if you've
seen this I think this joke is terrible
with these with these tattoos and well
you know that identifies him as a person
which is which is good you know we use a
human being but you know from the Joker
you know we want you know is more of
them an animal i would say you know so
we'll get the the best Joker that there
was Heath Ledger and you know you know
well yeah okay it says you know you see
I think this is more fitting for a for a
joker I would say oh one last one pills
these pills so these pills come out of
jelly beans but yeah I mean you can see
what it means you know you know if you
if you look far enough away i suppose
you might confuse them for for sweets as
well so so these are things you need to
know and I say okay well mr. point i'll
go with medication okay right so i
didn't even show that one thing is there
i suppose i should show it this one was
quite good I didn't show it it
identifies the federal of Walter White's
hat which is which good okay anyway so
what's happening behind the scenes so
this is a diagram I drew myself I'm not
going to lie it's not the most
attractive diagram in the world but it
basically outlines what what happens
when you drag and drop an image from
image identify and you get your result
so what happens is you go on image
identify com
you drag your image in and then the
image is shrunk now sometimes the
depending on various factors sometimes
the image is shrunk directly within your
within the browser before it gets sent
to us or the the image gets directly
uploaded and then the image gets the
image gets shrunk down so it depends but
once the image has been shrunk down to a
certain size there's some additional
image processing that's required to kind
of standardized the way that these
images work required for the the
algorithm and then you use the function
hash essentially which creates a hash of
of the image and then if an identical
hash exists in our database then it will
read the cash and then it will give you
a result if it doesn't know what the
image is it then runs image identify
again and then it writes to the cash and
then turns out result and then finally
you know you can give feedback you give
your feedback it goes to the algorithm
out the data gets put into the algorithm
and then that gets fed back into image
identify so the next time you use it you
may find that that stuff has changed so
yeah I mean most of this stuff happens
in the cloud so I'd like to say that
this like I put this nice cloud symbol
and stuff in this box to show you
basically what happens with the Wolfram
cloud so remote that processing is done
with the Wolfram proud I mean all of it
lives in the Wolfram cloud but but the
result of this Lee is displayed on your
page and stuff like that okay so
additional information on image identify
around 10,000 objects were originally
classified and now this is going up as
more and more people classified the
machine learning algorithm that's used
is convolutional neural networks which
is specifically quite good at handling
edges the way that we have this
structure which I'll talk to you about a
bit more
using image and wordnet so you have for
example you can have a animal and then
from an animal you can have various
animals of course it's dog cat wildcat
beast or something like that and then
let's say you go down from the dog you
can then have the type of dog so you can
check this out I'll show it as well so
this is basically where we got the most
of the data from but it required a lot
of cleaning from from our point of view
so we have a lot of researchers working
on cleaning the data from wordnet and
getting data from every stat so imagenet
is where we got most our photo images
there's 14 million photos on there and
then wordnet is where we get the the
word structure from okay so image
identify the function so this is a
function then you can use on your on
your machine and what happens is you
means you can integrate it within your
code of course you don't have to just
use the website this allows you to have
some additional options which I'll show
you and basically what happens is you
when you run the function image
identifies I'll run here I got this
picture of an ocelot I can use the
function image identify on the ocelot
and it returns this entity wild cat and
I can't highlight over it because I'm in
in in slideshow mode but it would say
entity a concept Wildcat so I've already
downloaded the pack layers stays on your
it stays on your machine and so all
these calculations that you'll see now
are done locally to my machine so you
don't require an internet connection
something you should know like that the
defile of the maximum file size that
this pack leur can be is 50 megabytes
and then that's your whole image
identify really good really really good
so you can integrate you into your code
quite readily without having to have a
internet connection now there are
options you can add to image identify so
you can allow you can ask image
identify to be more specific so here
I've got my well image identified
identified Ocelot as a wild cat and what
I can say is the second option you know
identify this image in the space of a
wild cat and they'll give me the result
Ocelot so I can look at some
probabilities as well so there's
additional options you can add so i can
say image identify of the image of the
Ocelot give me all well the top 10 the
top 10 results that this image can be
and we can see that it's got various
things wild cat cat and this is
depending on on how precise you want to
your your result to be I suppose and we
can see that Ocelot is there we can
actually have a look at the probability
so using the option probability and we
can see various probabilities of what
the likelihood it is or being X 1 Z so
the likelihood of being a cat is
ninety-nine percent likely you've heard
of it being wild cat is ninety-nine
percent so what we can do is we can go
to I'll actually show you wordnet which
is hopefully I can zoom in and I can
just type in our salon so you can you
can get an idea of how the structure
works because I don't think we have any
easy way to show you the structure right
now so we can see also opt and then we
can click on this is here and we can go
to inherited hyper name and we can see
the kind of structure is this is this
okay for you guys at the back maybe it's
a bit small so we can see is a lot if we
go up the tree we can see wild cat which
is a subclass of cats which is a
subclass of feline carnivore placental
animal mammal vertebrate etc etc until
we get up to whole unit physical this is
stuff we took out because we don't
really care about something being a
whole unit or a physical object or a
physical entity into the to an entity
this stuff isn't really useful for you
guys so we kind of stopped around where
we can have a look I suppose weeks
starting to stop around well maybe
organism mammal here so you can see all
those things
mentioned most of them actually on the
list is going down the tree and we can
see the probability to be so this is
interesting I've done the same for a
fruit and here i just show the kind of
the kind of tree structure so with this
fruit which actually was incorrectly
identified but i just used it as an
example anyway this is actually an apple
i'm pretty sure but it's identified it
as well a quince there 23% probability
so it went from a natural object to a
fruit to an edible fruit to a quince so
edible fruit I thought there was an
eighty-three percent probability and
then of that it thinks it's a 23%
probability that it was a quince and if
we have a look at Apple it had eleven
percent and eating apple ten percent and
then all of these things so one of the
things you can use as an option so that
one was the probabilities you can use
better specificity goal I can't
pronounce that very well so let's say I
have this image of my of my cat my
Ocelot sorry and what I can say is
specificity specificity goal is low Oh
specific that's right I maybe I spell it
wrong here okay okay maybe get that's
probably why was having trouble
pronouncing it and so you know I low
specificity low and at high whatever I
just said we can say Ocelot now let's
take this image of a golden retriever
and it tells me it's I think it's golden
retriever I'm not sure it says it's a
retriever and what I can do is I can you
can actually give a numerical value for
well for specificity specificity goal
between 0 and 1 so how specific you want
this to be so I'm going from 0 to 1 wait
no point two five steps just to show you
basically here chill I'll push this down
a little bit so you can see it at the
back that at zero it's animal nor 25
domestic dog domestic dog retriever nerf
I want maximum specificity it gives
golden retriever so we can get an idea
of how the structure works there as well
so there's a few ways that you can you
can see this so now we're going to talk
about the machine I mean I was talking
on machine learning I suppose but I want
to talk to you about well our machine
learning functions that you can use
today because this I mean you can use
the function image identify of course
but if you want to generate your own
machine learning example with your own
data and stuff currently we have two
functions classify and predict and what
do we well so it's what do we mean by
machine learning in these examples and
i'm going to show you this is but in
essence teaching a machine a task from
examples so what this means is in image
recognition we can feed it in pictures
of images and this is kind of how it
works on on on image identify we feed it
pictures and then we say what that
picture is in this case is a cat in this
picture is a dog etc if we want to do
text classification we can feed it in
sentences long strings and say you know
in this case whether it was a positive
statement or a negative statement or we
can actually factor in the talk that all
I'll give I'll give later I I do it with
Amazon reviews and star ratings and then
we can do prediction from features so if
you have multiple features in this case
you have two features in numerical
results and a nominal result we can say
we can give that the numerical value
here as well so what happens in
classifying our predict is we do some
pre-processing so we what we like to do
is try and make things as automatic as
possible at Wolfram I mean we like to
give you some some ops you know extra
options but in essence we want to make
for a user who doesn't know anything
about machine learning just be out to
throw some data at it and get it to work
because well it's more fun that way
and it's more useful if you're not if
you're not knowledgeable on that in that
field so I'll just run through this
quickly because I know I'm going to run
out of time so we extract features from
from from these from from from this data
so about pixel value or something like
that from images and from strings we
extract word tokens and things like that
we look if there's missing data and then
there are some algorithms which work
behind the scenes which replace missing
data with actual with actual data or
make some kind of best guess nominal
encoding are so certain characters need
to be encoded into into numerical values
we do some standardization
dimensionality reduction so if you're
your machine you your classifier has
multiple dimensions and it doesn't
actually require one of them then it can
reduce that and then finally feature
selection from that so that's so that's
the pre-processing court and then once
that's processed we go on to automatic
method selection so currently the
methods are the machine learning methods
that exist and these are the ones you
can you can look up online to get an
idea of what happens here are these are
these 7 a-7 here and basically what
happens is when you feed well show you
the function classifying you and you
just give it some values what it does is
it does some quick analysis comparing
logistic regression markov naive bayes
etc etc and sees which which that which
gives you the highest probability result
for what you want so if you know better
you can manually select the method but
the automated method works quite nicely
so then there's some hyper parameter
selection and then finally you get your
classifier and I just remind myself to
tell you that automation is key here
because we would get a very complicated
subject and
making things autumn I oughta mated is
really nice so actually let's show you
some code how you can actually do this
so we have predict function which says
okay the value one goes to one value to
goes to 3 325 etc etc and then we can
say what well that's what creates a
predictive function and we can see what
it's used it's used the method linear
regression feature type numerical and we
can expand that and it says you used for
examples and I can say okay what's the
probability of getting 2.5 so what if I
put the value 2.5 what does it think the
value is and it says 4.25 which is
somewhere between two and three classify
we have numbers here one and two
correspond to a string a and three and
four correspond to a string be not very
exciting but just a simple example again
as you actually use logistic regression
here and we can say what is what do you
think 2.3 is and it thinks it's a I
guess it's closest to to a here so so
yeah okay and then we can feed it
multiple features so here one red two
blue three blue and four red go to aabb
and then one is 1.5 red and based on
that it thinks that the result is a so
these are very simple examples let's try
make it a bit more interesting so here
we're getting some data from the Titanic
it's you can get this data example data
as a function really nice to get
specific examples for different areas in
this case we get the Titanic example for
a machine learning we grabbed some
random data just to see what it actually
looks like so it's got at the class of
the of the person in the Titanic at the
time what age they were what gender they
were and whether they survived or died
so we've got these multiple features and
you can see that there's a missing data
as well and we don't have to worry about
that we don't have to fill it in just
let Mathematica do the work for you now
we can just classify and we can see how
long it takes
to do the classifier takes no point 25
seconds it uses a logistic regression
and then I can say okay what did a first
class 20 year old female survive or die
in the Titanic and it says she survived
the third class 50 or female died and we
can get some more information out of
this using a option probabilities so we
can say okay what are the probabilities
that's a first class 20 year old female
survival died and we can see that it
thinks that is in ninety-nine percent
chance a survival with an oar point
naught wait no point five percent chance
of death isn't right yeah we can do that
for male and what we can see is that you
know if you're a male well it's not good
news for you so we can get some specific
information out of the out of the
classifier so there's a function called
classifier information so i won't go
into too much detail here but it gives
you some some general information and
you can explore more information from
classifier information so here just
tells me the method and what
regularization coefficients we use okay
so one of the options that exists is
performance goal so if you want training
speed to be extremely fast you can say
performance go goes to training speed
and then it will classify faster so here
we wear this is why i put the timing
here to ignore point two five seconds
originally and I said performance goal
goes to training speed and we can see
that it's taken all point 16 seconds but
you can imagine that it's going to be a
bit more inaccurate I also said that you
can choose the method specifically so if
I decide that I'm smarter than
Mathematica then i can say method goes
to logistic regression in this case
because i say the logistic regression is
better and i don't need to see
classifier information here and we can
see that it's chosen method logistic
regression because I forced it to and
then we can make a nice little ice a
nice fun example of 0 is a certainty Oh
have to make that shinier title or
subtitle oh that's not good about
chapter just cuz of the style sheet that
we use okay so fun example whether it
did you survive the Titanic or not so
sorry that's not good so let's say all
the second class and I were I am 27 now
actually and I'm a male my chance is a
survival eight percent but then if I
suddenly became female my chances grow
drastically to ninety-three percent and
we can make some we can make some nice
plots to plot where in this case first
class male and females and third-class
male and females and have a look at what
what the data actually looks like if you
know it fills in the gaps of the machine
learning which is quite nice and what we
can see is basically if you're a female
you're basically much more likely in any
class to have survived the Titanic which
is interesting information to know and
it didn't actually require that much
coding which is which is good digit
recognition so here we're getting some
data again I don't know how long this is
going to take maybe I shouldn't have I
shouldn't have done that because I think
I pre loaded the data so that we didn't
have to do this but basically we've got
some some data for our which is some
handwritten a handwritten digits now
this is going to not work for me now is
it oh no it's worked okay so what we can
see here is that we've got these in this
random sample that this zero has been
classified as a 05 has been classified
as a 57 as a seven although they're not
very good ones but there's 10,000 images
here and then we can classify in this
i'm not going to show you this
classifier now because I've got this I
got this nice I've got this nice little
manipulate which is created where I can
live show you some some similar scene
learning so I can just try and draw two
and you can see that it identifies that
it's a 27
seven is fine a four is usually quite
bad oh no that's okay but I think it
kind of thinks is a nine I guess if I
just join this on here then it would
become a nine I don't know if I can fix
this now right no but this is a good
example this is a good example of how
things work okay text this is a very
simple example actually you can find it
the documentation I've got a better
example that I'll show you I'll show you
shortly but yes we've got some text this
Cavett grade classifieds is an image so
you can say instead of giving string
results you can give anything as a
result in this case I'm giving an image
so cat is gray goes to a cat cat is fast
kappa gain dog dog and now i can feed it
in in this case two strings so you can
and we can see that nice cat and what a
dog will classify as a picture of a cat
and the picture of a dog and this is a
very nice example i think of showing the
value predict so predictors is for like
numerical results where you're not
captured putting things into categories
so we have these gauges so these are
images so we have this image and the
function actually created the data is
just here in I haven't run it here but
we have this this gauge which is at
Northpoint 908 nor point 378 etc etc and
this is you know this is just an image
followed by a numerical result and we
create our predictor it takes actually I
don't know how long it takes I okay not
too long it uses nearest neighbors and
feature type is image and I can feed it
in a new gauge so let's have a look what
this actually looks like just so you can
see it's at around nor point 75 and we
just feed it in this image and it says
it's not point 743 so I haven't really
done anything here I haven't done
anything really miraculous Mathematica
has done it for me it makes me look
smart so I can have a look at the
distribution of the data so one of the
options is distribu
I make it have a look at the the plot of
the distribution so it's yeah no point
743 plus or minus no point not one and
now i can create a dynamic module which
shows you the the angular gauge it
creates the image and then it does a
classification and and then feeds it
back into the back into the gauge to see
how well it does it classifying so I go
around here we can see that it's
actually quite you know there's some
little bits of hiccups here but it's
showing that nor point 5 is actually nor
point 5 nor point 6 is actually nor
point six etc etc which is really really
clever I'm very impressed by this I
don't care if you are I'm impressed you
know so there are built-in classifieds
as well and actually if you I'll show
you on the on the website if you grab a
picture of Obama for example so have
this lovely picture of Obama it's a bit
slow but this is fine and then I'll feed
it in here if it identifies as a person
then it will attempt to run the clock
the function classify notable person and
here it says Barack Obama which is which
is quite nice and you can use the
function notable person the class the
inbuilt classifier so you use the
function classify with the the
classifier in this case notable person
and there's the same image because well
I wasn't very imaginative and then it
comes up with Barack Obama and then here
I've actually got a picture of well
Christian Bale which I don't know it
looks a lot younger then then I'm used
to so if I feed this image so it's
christian bale very nice name age here
I've got this well it tries to classify
based on your name what age you should
be so Sally and it says if your name
Sally you're likely to be 63 years old
so we can actually have a look at the
distribution of this so we can have a
look at the distribution of the name
Sally over well 02 well in this case 0
to 100 years old and we can have a look
at the probability
distribution of the name of the name
salary based on age which is which is
really interesting as obviously you can
create these classifiers but they exist
for your use so here I've got I've got
this language customer I can't remember
what I wrote I just fed it into google
translate something about porkchop so I
like eating pork chops or something like
that and it just classifies the language
and here is the where you can feed it
multiple language multiple sentences and
I'm feeling it in English French Spanish
German Chinese Arabic and then Russian
and we can see that oh no Ukrainian okay
sorry I couldn't tell but yeah you can
see that I identify to him okay and
there are more as well I don't need to
show them all so you can see it's
country flag Facebook topic name gender
profanity sentiments Pat so all of these
exist and they do get updated just so
you know so one big example or big ish
Italy it's quite small to describe that
I wanted to show you which is based on
text analysis is is this recipe
classifier that my cup ex-colleague
Martin John Hadley made and I told i
told him that i mentioned his name
because you know he made this so it
seems fair enough so it's based on this
nature paper flavor network and the
principles of food pairing and the data
was basically the data has a list of
recipes so has the data which is a bunch
of ingredients followed by a cuisine so
where it comes from does it come from
Southeast Asia Eastern European Western
European North America and South
American executive tetra he has
absolutely 381 unique ingredients in
total 56,000 and it's taken from 56,000
recipes and the recipes are taken from
these websites as well so if you want to
create your own and then it's converted
into a classifier so literally we just
run classifier with ingredients followed
by cuisine a bunch of times and then I
package it into a cloud application
because I didn't mention this but
I develop on the cloud so I like to talk
about the cloud a lot so you can go on
this website made it public subnet
forward slash recipe door HTML and it
brings up this this form function a nice
still form function and yes look I even
even quoted him here I should say me
really because I made they made the this
bit but it wasn't very hard and I just
feed it in some ingredients so let's say
let me think of a South American dish
way like the heaters or something like
that so I'll give it onion actually rice
tomato and avocado and then I click
Submit and we get a graph of what the
probability of the cuisine was so we can
see here that is ninety percent chance
that it's that it's Latin American so
yeah by all means try this yourself you
know I can start just feed it in bacon
eggs potato beans
and what are we got here Eastern
European or Western European so forty
three percent chance thirty percent
chance this is a nice marriage of
machine learning and the cloud it was
actually very simple to make this
actually I would show you the code but I
don't really have time but if you if you
want to see it I can show you after the
talk so i wanted to show like a dynamic
image identify so let me just fire up my
camera and hopefully actually works oh
dear that's not good please don't I mean
these are not supported functions oh
dear i may i may have killed my
Mathematica so I'll just kill it now and
start again to save time and bring up my
keynote and what page were we on dynamic
image identified so I wanted to show you
an example I suppose so this is exact
well this is what what Conrad showed so
i won't i won't show it in too much
detail but i just want to set the scene
I suppose and are you going to work for
me I would like you to work for me what
where the coke go yeah this is nice one
of the things I realized that chili is
that song I found out that some of my
functions weren't working it turned out
that i was using a development version
of Mathematica without realizing until
last night about 11pm so I don't have
enough I don't have a dynamic of enabled
it going to work for me now I don't have
a legitimate copy that you would
download on my machine as it happens
which makes me think okay so this is
just to show you this is what this is
what Conrad basically showed and there's
me being a person so what I wanted to do
is
if anyone was at the London conference
what i did is i had a raspberry pi and
basically i showed some I I basically I
cooked it up with a infrared camera and
it detected movement and if it detected
movement it will take a picture and then
send an email so in this case okay I
probably should have explained before I
was away from the thing but basically
it's going to wait until it detects a
person when it detects a person it's
going to send me an email to say that
there was an intruder so I should move
into moving to screen it says found sure
and then I should we have to go to my my
emails as long as things work please
have worked ice probably has something
to do with this no okay I'm gonna run
that because that will show you my
password um well we'll see if it pops up
anyway let's just pretend that you know
the email sent and it was really really
clever but I want you know I'm running
out of time now so very quickly 10.2
what's going to be coming in 10.2 image
identify should be sped up at the moment
it takes at least on my machine half a
second to do image identify it should be
a factor six five or six speed up up to
a factor there are two functions at
least which are being added in 10.2 one
is fine formula and the other is text
cases so I'll just fire this up very
quickly and Michael my fine formula
staff not very elegantly displayed here
but let's say I've got some data some
linear data i can say fine formula on
this data and this is using machine
learning algorithm so i don't have to
specify any any information here just
the data and then fine formula gives me
a formula and i can see how well
actually fit a little bit of a bigger
example is this is this exponential fit
and then i can do fine formula and then
here is here is my formula fitted so I
haven't given it any parameters
whatsoever I'll just let it do its thing
text cases
here text cases are picks out in this
case words from from text currency
amount nouns verbs and in the future it
will be able to take countries and
you'll be able to say extract from this
data all sentences which contain a
country and stuff like that okay and
then beyond this we're going to have
trainable classifiers I knew the
convolution on your networks algorithm
will be pushed into mathematica directly
and then we're going to be working
heavily on image sound and text
processing in the current future so
concluding remarks well basically
everything's great image to identify is
awesome and it's just the beginning of
what we what we can do with
classification so finally so you know
I'm sure you enjoyed your talk now is
there more yes there is a5 p.m. today I
have a talk project I school I said
projects in machine learning but
actually it's a single project in the
Dow room not the Jones room and
basically it's going to be a
start-to-finish project in data
extraction followed by classification
and how to optimize this so thank you
very much for listening